welcome to the old Wilson meditation
part to the beach now close your eyes
imagine yourself at the beach maybe a
Hawaiian island I don't know you pick
which one
it's nerd day cuz rise relax breathe in
breathe out
it's a gorgeous blue sunny day clear
skies
imagine your toes in the sand their cute
little toes there's some hairs on your
big toes
I've never mind that maybe there's a
little sand crab any and he comes by and
snaps at your little pinky tone you good
you say hey get out of your little sand
crab you're cute but go I'm trying to
meditate focus on your breath if there's
any thoughts that arise just acknowledge
them wave hi to them and then wave
goodbye goodbye thoughts get back to
focusing on your smelly breath I'm
kidding it's a joke
okay your breath is and smelly or maybe
it is I don't know I'm not near you my
breath does smell it smells like cabbage
you're sitting in the Sun maybe sit in
the shade so you don't get Sun freckles
okay use your head
you're getting those freckles that look
like chocolate chips I love chocolate
chips I do but I don't want them on your
bony get in the shade now maybe you hear
the sound of a sweet ukulele in the
background don't open your eyes keep
them closed
the
over the rain oh hi I'm so hot right now
it's not even funny
dreams and dream Oh once and no long
I saw
Oh birds fly our Bluebird on the trains
that intrigue dumb dreams really do come
true
here they do
now imagine a volcano in the background
it's erupting it's erupting like a
pimple on your face go get out of there
what are you doing why are you MUC
meditating right near volcano so
disappointed that you want to meditate
Nero volcano
Wow Wow right this meditation has come
to an end I'm just so mad yeah
namaste